so here is how this is going to work I
think that Jen is going to give us
some more perspectives on that but we
will start with a conversation here some
questions
we will talk about the process overall
and then we will open for Q a okay so
get prepared get your questions ready
and once your map here everybody's going
to join the Q a is that right yep that's
right Michelle
um well thank you both for joining us
for this conversation
Simon I want to start with you
um you're a big believer in purpose why
what do you see the power of purpose for
an organization like ours
so
my love and my
focus on purpose had nothing to do with
business it came from my own Journey
where I had lost my own passion for my
own work
and superficially my life looked fine
and good I owned my own business we had
good clients we did good work but I
didn't want to wake up and go to work
anymore
um and so that was embarrassing quite
frankly I was embarrassed to like admit
that I was unhappy when superficially
things looked looked well and so most of
my energy went into pretending that I
was happier more in control and more
successful than I felt
um which is not a great place to be and
uh it wasn't until a dear friend of mine
came to me came to me and said
something's wrong
um was I able to take all of that energy
that I was going into lying hiding and
faking and to find a way to restore my
passion and what I discovered was based
on the biology of human decision making
this little this little model why how
and what and I realized I knew how I did
things and I knew what I did but I
didn't know why and so the idea of
purpose has nothing to do with business
it's a deep-seated human need our need
to belong is deeply ingrained in us and
if you consider the company as just the
modern day tribe and the more we feel
like we belong to our tribe and the more
that we feel that our our company and
our our work has
um has meaning Beyond just the money we
make in the product we sell it actually
is incredibly fulfilling and Incredibly
joyful and
um it just so happens it's exceptionally
good for business
organizations that
um have a clear sense of purpose use
that sense of purpose to make decisions
higher to that sense of purpose build
structure incentives around that purpose
tend to outperform tend to out innovate
their competitors over the long term
almost almost always
thank you
and Michelle you know looking a little
bit about why now is the right time you
know hearing Simon talk about the power
of purpose for an organization and what
it can bring to the table for our people
and how we operate
you know we've had a couple
conversations over the last few years
about who we are as a company and where
we're going and how we want to be
perceived not just by our employees and
our colleagues here but more broadly by
our competitive set and by people
outside of the industry why was now the
right time to tackle this
so I don't think that there is like a
right time but we actually had a great
opportunity
and I always had like this
healthy dissatisfaction with the way
that we were communicating our purpose
in the way that we were talking to
people and there was this never-ending
conflict of people like me that are for
more than 20 years in the company and
that we share this passion and
immigration
uh sense of
Noble mission for doing what we do and
get confronted all the time by people
that are joining the company that were
great people asking us questions of
why do we exist what would the company
Miss if the ABI would not be here and I
always thought that our our answers were
like sometimes
either superficial
or they were not really well thought to
address the changes in society and the
reason why people are asking this
question
it was because they deeply care about
this purpose was not just a question in
there but we were trying to give answers
that were very shallow and that thing
was like
was inside me growing for the years and
I had this conversation with Britt what
I said it cannot keep trying to to
answer this if averages the average
opinion of everybody I want to to give a
try and bring the best people that we
can and try to get to an answer to that
that is massive transformational that
mobilizes people that brings more is
Miles than uncertainty and that people
really engage with and then a lot of
people came together it was super funny
it's even a question that I have for you
by the way I will link this on the
question because one of these minutes of
insanity when we were talking about that
I said I want everybody that knows how
to build this that is really any
specialist and is good at that
I want to bring Simon sinek and then
there was this silence at the table and
people said what are we talking about
how are you going to bring this guy here
and then I said yes I want to bring him
and then I think that we we set Marcel
on a mission together we fighting
Kennedy and we start talking to people
here and there and someone
found a way that is always a way to talk
to you
and it was super funny because at Prince
at the beginning people came and said oh
he's going to join you for like a
30-minute session
but we we have to to let him know that
one he doesn't do this job
two he doesn't engage on companies
whatever he talks about the topic but
he's not going to do the work with you
and then I was incredibly frustrated and
say why not if this guy is the good one
he's going to come here to say okay so
give me one meeting with him
give me the 30 minutes
and I'm sure that we can sell him the
passion and bring him along and he's
going to engage and help us
if he does not
we go for the second choice third choice
we find a way to do this ourselves and
then I was always curious to to
understand the perspective from your
side because was this this group of
crazy people talking all together trying
to convince you to join and I'm so happy
and so glad that at the end you you
helped us and we continue to engage and
talk after all these months
sounds so like
like I'm hidden away that they don't let
me out of my box
the the uh
the reason is was um
a long time ago I made a strategic
decision that
I when I realized the power of this
little idea I had a I had some choices
to make right where I could build a
business around it become a consultant
you know make good money build a
consultancy around this idea that was
option number one and option number two
was to to become a preacher for a new
way of thinking about business and to
work and devote my life to undoing
everything that Jack Welch did
um
and and I made a strategic choice that I
would that I would that I would preach
and so it
and my goal was to get to as many people
in as many organizations as possible
um to spread this message
um and so I would often get invitations
to come and like become a consultant
but what I always viewed it it would
take me away from spreading the message
you know rolling up my sleeves for two
years to work with one company is
amazing
but I I'm trying to change the way we
think about business
the great news is is that the movement
is growing you know when I started first
started talking about purpose a bunch of
years ago it was a it was like hippie
dippy stuff you like you know you didn't
talk about purpose at work
um work was serious
um and uh and now I love the fact that
major corporations at the highest levels
are talking about the power of purpose
because you felt it you felt like it was
superficial I love that it's deeply
human you're sort of reinforcing what we
said a moment ago
um and quite frankly a lot of companies
pay purpose lip service because it's
fashionable right and so every company
has a purpose statement on their website
but the question is do they use that
purpose statement to make decisions are
they using it to build their strategies
and the answer is woefully small
um I'll give you one silly example you
know uh and I I think it's one of the
ones I wrote about
um
which is a pharmacy for example you know
uh if you go to Walgreens their purpose
statement is to help our customers be
healthy and what something like that you
know whatever it is and then you walk
through their stores and they sell
cigarettes and other really bad things
and if you ask them why do you do that
they're like well I mean the margins are
great you know it's like but what about
your purpose in other words they never
meant it
it was never serious and quite frankly
when we met I was just blown away by
your honesty and your passion and the
fact that you that you do recognize that
there's new ways to run business
um uh
yeah I was just I was just completely
just drawn to the people and that you
really really do believe in this stuff
and I find that very attractive and if
you can change the way you do business
you can influence the way other people
do business
um at the risk of talking for too long
um you know GE back in the day was the
leadership Factory in the world that if
you had GE on your resume that was
enough to qualify you to go run any
other company you know
um well that didn't work you know the
model many of those Executives drilled
those companies into the ground GE is a
shadow of its former self and it wasn't
built to last
um and no one has replaced GE as the
leadership Factory for the world because
the old models if you think about it we
all came up with with the Jack Welch
thinking we all grew up and became
Executives in that world and so the
talent pool for a new way of thinking a
business is zero
foreign
exciting
is that it is a there's an amazing
opportunity for a large company to
reinvent literally how business is done
just like GE reinvented it for those
strange times
my question is why not Abi
like why not ABI that the way that you
will imagine purpose the way that you'll
imagine leadership the way that you will
run your business will be not based on
Old thinking but based on new thinking
and that Simply Having ABI on your
resume qualifies you to be the CEO of
absolutely any company in absolutely any
industry no one has replaced GE my
question is why not you and that's what
drew me to you
Simon following on from that um I think
we've we've all had the benefit of
hearing Michelle talk about our purpose
we dream big to create a future with
more cheers
um and we've heard the passion in his
voice and we've heard him refer to our
purpose specifically as magical is that
something that you feel is unique to ABI
in terms of having a CEO as well as a
company and employees that feel so
passionately about our purpose the
simple answer is yes
um the simple answer is yes I'm
um and I'll you know refer to the answer
I gave a moment ago which is a lot of
the leaders of major public companies
came up through the old system and so
you know what got me here may not get me
there but the fear of changing what I
was raised to believe over a 20 or 30
year career you know it's largely fear
because this is what I know I'm really
good at this I perfected it it got look
where it got me why would I change
you know and I think it takes tremendous
courage to say yes that was great but
that what got us here will not get us
there and to challenge oneself and
challenge one's company is is pretty
rare in especially for large public
companies and so sort of following on to
that I I I assume and you can both maybe
speak to this that you both see purpose
as a major driver or a catalyst for
opportunity for a company
I mean yes I mean the simple answer is
yes I think we all agree uh and you and
I definitely agree
um but I think it's also
um
if you just look at if you look at this
Young Generation who's coming up you
know remember that they grew up in the
old in the old model more important
their parents worked in the old model
and so I hear so many people complain
that this Young Generation shows no
loyalty to the company they're in and
out well remember they watch their
parents get laid off because the company
missed its arbitrary projections the
company was profitable just not as
profitable as they promised and so their
parents lost their jobs right so why
should they be loyal to the company
that's what they saw no loyalty to their
parents and it was not a meritocracy
their parents had woodworking were
working hard and so I don't blame them
and so they organically are challenging
the old systems because it doesn't feel
right
um and they're looking for companies to
respond to that and most companies
either pay it lip service or or just
don't and so I think any company that
ignores
changing tides of the world will find
themselves playing defense and playing
catch-up in a few years as that
generation gets older because they're
demanding it and they're not wrong
thinking through kind of the opportunity
here
um one of the things that we had talked
about when we were creating the purpose
statement was that it would be something
that was true today but also would live
in through the future can you talk about
why that's so important for an
organization like ours
so I'm a I'm a devotee and complete
fanatic for the infinite game and having
an infinite mindset
and very quickly
um just a quick definition so you know
what I'm talking about
um Dr James Carson the mid-1980s defined
these two types of games find out games
and infinite games
a finite game is known players fixed
rules and agreed upon objective
football baseball there's always a
beginning middle and an end and if there
is a winner necessarily they have to be
losers then you have infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players which means new players
can join any time and you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are I mean you definitely don't
know every Brewery in the world you know
the rules are changeable which means
every player can play however they want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
um turns out business is an infinite
game you know when Circuit City went
bankrupt Best Buy didn't win anything
um uh they had to keep playing
uh companies come and go and yet the
game continues with you or without you
and there's no such thing as winning
nobody wins business it doesn't exist
um but if you listen to the language of
too many leaders it becomes abundantly
clear they don't always know the game
they're playing in they talk about being
number one or being the best or beating
their competition
based on what you know and I love it
when Executives come to me and say you
know we are number one and I always say
for now
you know
um and so and so
um the idea of building a company that
can survive every single employee in
this room after you've long gone and
that that company remains true to its
purpose
um is a very very powerful thing a great
example is right outside the front door
you know the Walt Disney Company
um you know the purpose that Disney
founded and they've they've gone through
you know trials and tribulations for
sure
um ins and outs but for the most part
you know when they are at their natural
best they are they hearken back to their
founding purpose and I love that I love
that uh you know you ask me is it
essential
I mean depends on what kind of company
you want to run
um if you want a company that that can
continue to innovate and set set the
course for what business should look
like Define what Innovation looks like
in your industry long before you're all
you know long after you're all gone then
build that company but if you want to
build a company that just
um sucks the life out of people who work
there and does damage the you know to
the industry all the name of it does
damage to the the communities in which
we work all in the name of short-term
gains you can build that company too and
it'll come at a much steeper cost
um in terms of Love loyalty you know
Etc et cetera so
yeah maybe I'm just a crazy idealist so
I think Simon as far as the infinite
game is concerned um and I think yeah I
know we have one zone for example that
has fully adopted the infinite game
um and I imagine we as ABI knowing
Michelle we want to be infinite players
but we've heard from speakers yesterday
and today that have talked about sort of
the tension between you know needing to
meet short-term metrics and having our
eye on the long-term strategic objective
and those metrics having everything to
do with quarterly earnings as well as
you know the annual targets that we set
for ourselves and we live and die by so
and this question is both for Michelle
as well as for you Simon you know I
guess from an ABI perspective how can we
be an infinite player and align that
tension yeah so we can still meet our
metrics as well as have that sort of
long-term growth strategy so the the
infinite game is not the absence of
finite games
um you can absolutely have arbitrary
goals and remember most of the financial
goals we set a few people sat in a and
said what do we want our annual goal to
be and somebody says let's make it this
number and somebody goes no let's make
it this number and that becomes the
number right there's nothing wrong with
that absolutely nothing in fact it's
necessary human beings are very tangibly
driven animals we like counting things
it's actually important can you imagine
running a marathon without mile markers
it would actually be unnerving so
metrics help us measure speed and
distance which is very very important
but we have to remember that when we hit
a metric or don't hit a metric the game
has not been won or lost
they're markers right and and that's the
important part so stop thinking we have
to stop thinking about business like a
race or a game and start thinking of it
like a lifestyle so for example I want
to be healthy right so there are many
things I have to do to be healthy I have
to eat right I have to exercise I have
to you know get enough sleep I have to
nurse my personal relationships there's
probably 15 or 20 other things can't do
all of those things well all the time
it's a striving same in business we have
you know we have product we have
marketing we have sales we have
leadership can't do them all right all
the time it's a striving but we can set
arbitrary goals like I want to lose x
amount of weight by X date
right and every day I'm going to stand
on the scale some days I'll feel good
and some days I'll feel bad and when I
hit my goal I'm excited
um but the problem is I have to keep
exercising for the rest of my life like
it hasn't ended simply because I hit a
goal and that's important to recognize
but what I find more interesting is what
happens if you miss the goal and the
answer is
nothing
nothing happens in fact very often we
just miscalculated the the time it'll
take to achieve it so if you're doing
all the right things and you you see the
trend data is is on path
and you just lose that weight in
a month later or two months later
okay you're healthier now even missing
the goal than you were before the the
bad news the where it gets dangerous is
when we're so obsessed with that goal
that I'll starve myself and stop
drinking water to hit the goal and I'm
actually unhealthy and companies do that
so the goals are good and celebrating
the wins are great and there are wins
that's fantastic but we have to remember
that if we miss the goal the question is
what's the trend data like are we a
healthy company are we taking care of
each other and I'll just go back a few
years ago
um
uh uh
Ginny remedy uh
IBM missed its numbers
and Ginny Romiti made of an internal
video which of course leaked made an
internal video
that was spread out set up to the entire
IBM that basically
all over the sales team publicly
and I remember talking to somebody at
IBM and I'm like What's with that video
and they're like oh so glad I'm not in
sales right and basically berated them
for missing the numbers this was the
first time IBM had missed its numbers
the first quarter in 69 quarters
and the CEO's response was to berate a
team the rate and higher division right
after 69 quarters they missed their
first one guess what happened after that
berating the team and what happened to
the culture and guess how many times
they missed it after that it continued
in other words it's fine it's fine to
miss it it's a game it's a long game so
I think that's where we get confused
which is we become obsessed with we
missed our numbers once we're we're
doing fantastic
you know so I think that's where it's
just about keeping things in perspective
that's why the infinite mindset helps
it's just about perspective
can I just compliment on that because
they think that in our case we've been
discussing this in the last two days and
it's a very important topic for us
because sometimes we set ourselves the
wrong goals
or even if we set the right goals the
right targets to simplify the way that
we measure then we get too obsessed with
that Target in the behavior that follows
is the wrong Behavior so we've been
talking here for example about the
Beyond beard space which are these
liquids that they address needs that
consumers have
but that beer
does not serve them because they like
sweeter liquids or higher alcohol
liquids or mixed liquids and this is an
incredible opportunity for us
one target can be a given number of net
revenue
but this is not why we are going Beyond
beer we are going Beyond beer because we
want this future with more cheers we
want to attract more consumers to our
franchises so we need to expand
penetration bring more consumers into
the category and the net revenue is just
a consequence of that it's just a
milestone a mark
but if people start trying
to achieve that Target so hard and so
obsessed then they would do like
unhealthy sales
that will not turn in the point of sales
that will leave retailers upset with our
product with the wrong impression that
the capital is trapped there and then we
lose the long-term game which is
attracting more consumers to the
category and we have made like a huge
change on our compensation and rewards
model to rebalance short and long term
in a way that people get free of this
Obsession of this 12 months targets and
trying to get there and the other thing
that I I agree 100 here my example is a
much
uh shallow one but I love like sports
and I love all type of sports and one of
the sports that I follow is like
martial arts
and that is this fighter which I think
that's one of the best ever his name is
khabib
and this guy came up with one idea that
is like he always talks when he's
fighting the other guy's Trash Talk he
talks like serious stuff
and he was saying in one of these world
championship fights like win or lose
doesn't matter
I know how much I put into I know that
I'm giving it all here today
and if God helps I will win
if not I will lose and I'll come back
because this guy he is focused on that
fight
but he knows what he wants for the long
term yeah so winner lose it today
circumstance when in the long term I
know where I'm going to and I think that
this is a little bit of this idea of
quarter by quarter there will be win and
lose and we need to get used to that
because you learn a lot when you lose
but if you are training hard yeah if you
are exercising every day if you are
attracting more consumers every day if
you are working together with your
community retailers each and every day
then in the long term I have little
doubts that you can win yeah right and
this to me is this this beauty of the
idea of the infinite game which I think
that fits super well for purpose because
there is no final milestone for a future
of Marchers yeah it really comes
together very well on the idea and what
you're capturing beautifully with that
story is
the ultimate the the ultimate competitor
in an infinite game is yourself it's
fundamentally a game of constant
Improvement that's all it is because you
know as we said before if a company goes
bankrupt nobody else wins anything it's
also a game where two organizations who
sell similar products at similar price
and similar quality can both be wildly
successful at the same time you know
even if the numbers are like this
um uh and so I think what you're talking
about is exactly right which is the game
is constant Improvement and the losses
reveal to you opportunities to improve
well I think constant Improvement is
something that we always strive for at
ABI
um you know Michelle it sounds like
you're really talking about the fact
that if we all focus on bringing our
purpose to life you know focused on
dreaming big to create a future with
more cheers that we'll all see the
benefits from that can you talk a little
bit about how you want everyone in this
room to help bring that purpose to life
yeah I think that the
the first point on that and I I like to
repeat this over and over again I think
that we had like a couple of amazing
moments when we were working on this
purpose and one came from one question
that you asked which was
what is that
very own thing that defines your culture
and that is there since the foundation
as you do this Soul search you always
remember that that was part of the
company and we came up with this monster
this is dream big and this was in our
face all the time right and then there
was the idea we dream big to something
and this is really how we create more
opportunities to people how we have a
higher impact in the society how we help
the economies of this community where we
operate our business how our retailers
grow their business so we can grow
together with them and this is a job
that's like it's easy to Define
come up with the purpose of the
direction but the execution is very
granular right the execution depends on
each and every country in each and every
region and in the leaders that we have
here at the room that's why every time
that I go to visit a different country
to talk to people I want to know what
they are doing that is related to our
purpose so I can come back and tell
these stories right so I think that what
I expect is people really
walk the talk and leave what we are
discussing and trying to build together
because there are plenty of
opportunities out there and no one
person can execute all of them so we
need everybody to work together but
maybe you can also compliment and tell
me how do you see the role of these
people here we have them not the top one
percent of the company we have the top
0.1 percent of the company in the room
and they are the people that really
drive and manage the company in the
day-to-day because they are very close
to the operations to the communities to
the suppliers to the the customers that
you have so how do you see their role in
making this purpose now come to life and
really have the full impact that we
expect to have they offer the most they
first of all they have the most
um wonderful job in the world which does
to take care of people I mean you know
the responsibility of most senior
leaders is that not to actually do the
work of their departments but to take
care of the people who are doing the
work in their departments and that new
skill set that that growth opportunity
to become a great leader is magical and
when you see people do things when you
see people dream big to do something
that creates a world with more cheers
like when you see them do that it's like
a parent catching you know you're
catching your kids doing something
wonderful or sharing or helping another
child it's like you realize oh my God
it's all worth it all the sacrifice all
that time it's all worth it so
leadership is a magical thing and to be
a student of leadership is is wonderful
so that's one the other thing is is
there's an opportunity for massive
creativity you know the the the thing
that I like about your purpose statement
and and I would from I would do one
slight thing which is to drop the we
I mean you can keep it up obviously I'm
just saying practically
um uh when you say dream big and it
becomes an instruction
right like you you literally can go back
to your people and say dream big I mean
that that's what I want you to do and
and understand what it means so how I
interpret the cheers is I mean there's
the obvious one right you know the the
there's beer but but cheers is is it's
more than celebration it's it's it
requires at least two people
and what I love about it is it's about
it's about Community it's about people
coming together whether it's happy or
sad it's about people taking care of
each other and and I love how you're
pushing people to to rethink how we do
things so that people come together and
produce something that's worth
celebrating at some point
um and it doesn't have to do with
product I mean as I said before I'm
realizing as I'm as I'm thinking this
through you know that challenge of you
know if if GE was the leadership Factory
in the past why not ABI for the future
like We're Dreaming big and coming up
with a reason to say look what we've
accomplished in the world we've changed
the course of global business I mean
that has nothing to do with beer but it
has everything to do with your purpose
and I think that's the challenge and
opportunity everybody here has which is
some of what you are able to bring to
life with your purpose is in product
absolutely and in sales and marketing
and all the things that you'd expect
um but some of it is actually how you
actually do business
and your ability to interpret that cause
that purpose through the actual business
I think is is what makes your purpose
actually have longevity which it's it's
more than just a product statement or a
statement of like what we want to
achieve in the world you know based on
numbers or metrics it's actually a
statement of how we think and how we
approach problems and how we tackle
problems and I think that's the most
important thing and the most important
thing is you have to practice it meaning
um you have to come together and work
together and help each other because
this is about Community it is about
cheers well and I think to that point
Simon one of the five pillars of your
book is specifically trusting teams and
when you talked about IBM for example
missing their target
um you know among other things it sounds
like a culture issue and a communication
breakdown so when you look at ABI I
think everybody can agree we're really
far along on you know purpose otherwise
known in your book as just cause
trusting teams and culture is hugely
important to ABI when you look at ABI or
you look at other companies what are
sort of the key elements to building
those trusting teams and I would ask
Michelle as well what does he want to
see from us as far as you know the
leaders of the company in terms of how
we build those trusting teams so number
one trust is a Feeling
you can't order people to trust you
um and simply being smart or getting
something right does not produce Trust
let's be Crystal Clear what a trusting
team is we've all been on one in the
past maybe and I hope you're on one
right now
um we've all been on trusting teams
where we have psychological safety to
say out loud I made a mistake
or I need help or I don't know
or I've got some stuff at home and I'm
struggling and it's affecting my work
product and I need help without any fear
of humiliation retribution and it'll
affect your promotability that's what
being an interesting team is and that's
what we have to build for the people who
work for us not being on a trusting team
we've also all been there unfortunately
where we're afraid to say I made a
mistake we would never say I don't know
something or don't understand something
we would never ask for help because it's
we're either going to get humiliated
publicly or we're going to affect our
promotability
um and the opportunity to build trusting
teams is what leadership is all about
um that's that's where the the strength
of culture comes from
so uh so yeah it's it's it's it's
essential to building any kind of
business short term or long term
um but definitely definitely a long-term
company for sure and all the stuff you
talk about challenging and pushing
boundaries means if you're pushing
boundaries and you're thinking big
you're going to fall a lot it happens
there's no such thing as innovation
without experimentation and
experimentation inherently requires
failure and I think a lot of companies
that are too finite-minded they fear
failure they fear well let me let me
restate I actually don't like the word
failure you know you hear you hear it a
lot which is you know uh we have a fail
fast culture you know I I think the
problem with the word failure is it's
like the word cancer which is there's a
huge difference between stage four liver
cancer and melanoma and a mild melanoma
but they're both called cancer that's
the problem and there are failures which
are minor and overcomeable and there are
failures that are catastrophic but the
problem is they're both called failure I
like the word falling failure we should
work very hard to avoid but Falling we
should encourage because you can get
back up I know of one large gaming
company and I love this
um that they they don't have parties
when they hit their goals they have
parties when they fail they have they
have parties when a game completely is a
complete blowout
because they're trying to acculturize
being comfortable with missing a goal or
or complete abject failure and they have
a party and they have their own
champagne which it has a label on it
um their own label I think it's called
they're called lessons and on the back
of those champagne bottle after the
party they actually write the lessons
they learn from the failure and so it's
a comfortable it's very comfortable it's
a company that's very comfortable with
failing which means they try again very
easily and they're super innovative
so creating a culture where falling is
is part of the game right I think it's
wonderful it has to be celebrated I love
it and interestingly I'll tell you when
I interviewed with Michelle Michelle you
spoke to me about how specifically
special the culture of ABI is can you
talk a little bit about that and I also
both have had the privilege of being
offered help and been told to ask for
help by you how did you come to this
sort of way of leadership
so if I go back to to the previous
question before answering that I think
that trust is that the the very center
of building teams and having engaged
teams and trust is earn it
is not given it's not because you are
the direct or the vice president that
people trust you
and you need to earn every day because
every day you have a different situation
today I'm happy tomorrow I have a
problem at home that day after tomorrow
I made something right and the next day
I did something wrong so people need to
one earn the trust second I really think
that this idea of
exposing the vulnerabilities
talking about things that do not work
not having a theater of just greens and
success in things that you achieve it is
super super important in build interest
I love the conversations that I have
with people when people come to talk to
me and say let me share with you the
things that are not working
and here is what you are trying to learn
and get organized so we can fix that so
this is like the best way for it to
start any conversation because then you
can really focus on what matters in
getting the business to be better and
sometimes you see people trying to
handpick and choose kpis to tell you a
story in which everything is beautiful
but the numbers and the data and in
today's world we have visibility of
everything you know what's working
what's not working in terms of culture I
always like to to think that our culture
is very simple
travels everywhere I actually always
spoke about that so I had the chance to
manage our business in China and find
the amazing people that understand our
culture and live through the same
principles and perform at very high
level in China or in the United States
or in Latin America simple
is a high performance culture so people
they like to think that they can run it
well lose weight compete and party and
do everything at the same time so people
are very active and it's a culture that
when people like
they really feel good about and they
want to have a contribution
when they don't like
it's very hard for you to be in that
place because if you'd agree too much if
you don't want Candor if you don't want
to talk about problems if you want to
hide yourself
is very difficult because you don't have
like closed offices because we have
performance targets because we do
perform as appraisal and my my
recommendation for people from outside
is what I told you is
speak up
look for people to help you every time
that you have an idea bring this forward
don't let people just shut you down and
at the end they always tell people if
you have any issues that you cannot
solve come to me or help you uh
and it's a simple culture that's what I
like it's like I like to think that we
are all like
athletes we want to perform and improve
our own marks and we can do this with
people that are in the same team as us
so that that's what our culture is about
great that's nice I want to make sure we
have time for audience questions
um so we'll ask one more question here
and then we'll go to the audience love
it
um Michelle you talk a lot about how
reputation isn't is a driver for us from
a commercial strategy perspective can
you just touch on how you think our
purpose really helps bring that to life
and what you see it going forward
helping us build to
yeah I'll go quick so we can open up I'm
sure that you guys are craving to ask
questions for Simon we've been seeing
each other already for like 24 hours but
I think that the the very simple thing
it is
we have an amazing company
we are part of an incredible industry
and an incredible category so be it is a
big category I repeat this all the time
one out of a hundred jobs out there is
related to our industry from farming
to the retailers and bars and
restaurants one out of a hundred we have
a huge impact in the communities where
we operate we have a categories very
inclusive men women
young old it doesn't matter where you
come from you can always sit drink a
beer talk and that's gonna serve you in
many different purpose shapes and forms
it's very natural for ingredients
right so badly East Water Hops and you
have these incredible beers in this very
local right so different from other
companies we are not like designing Palo
Alto and produce it in Bangalore and in
Bangladesh or somewhere in China so we
have businesses across 50 plus countries
several factories and people and
communities that rely on the work that
we do but we have not been telling our
story out there all the time
and because of that others start to tell
our story and build the reputation that
we need to live with because we don't
have the courage to go there and tell
our story and say what we stand for and
what we do and the most incredible thing
is that when people get to know us
the more they know the more they like so
we're wearing this event that they just
was sharing here the the the result of
the work that you all do and I start
talking to people in Washington and you
can imagine the conversations the
audience and people and the conversation
was two minutes five minutes 15 minutes
and was Unstoppable
at one point in time we were talking for
more than an hour and people continue to
ask questions about what we do in Africa
how do you support the retailers in
Mexico how is this thing of Designing
the seeds that we use for bodily in
Argentina in Brazil and people don't
really know the beauty that exists
inside the bi and I think that as we
work together collectively to tell our
story to build a reputation then it's
always easier to open any door to do
business to bring Partners in to have
more people sharing their dreams with us
because we'll never be able to realize
all the dreams only by ourselves we need
Partnerships we need expansions of the
company we need to bring people to work
with us and help us to achieve what we
want to achieve and this is what
reputation is it takes a life to build
what you need to build and you need to
take care because if you lose for one
moment it's gone forever right then if
not us to bring the reputation of the
beer category if not us to build the
reputation of ABI who then right so we
need to tell our story I'm living proof
of that by the way which is you know of
course I know Anheuser-Busch you know I
knew some of your Brands not all of them
and like whatever beer you know and when
I got to know you you know I fell for
something and saw something that I
didn't know
and and
understand that that there's something
really pretty magical going on here and
narrative really matters
um and your ability to tell your story
that goes beyond product is is I think
an amazing opportunity so that people
shouldn't have to get to have them they
shouldn't have to have a meeting with
you to know how magical you are you know
um uh it only reinforces it if I may
um you know I talk about the concept of
worthy rivalry which is the other
companies out there who you know do
things better than you so you can learn
from them and
the way that Phil Knight used to talk
about Nike I don't know if you've ever
heard the story
um he was speaking at a large conference
a thousand someone people whatever it
was and you know the most CEOs as you
know and they show up to talk about
their companies they talk about
revenues and market share and you know
and he stood up and he said to the
audience if any of you have ever run for
exercise can you please stand up most of
the room stood up he said um
if you run at least once a week
please keep standing everybody else sit
down most rooms sits down he says if you
run on you know twice a week please keep
standing
he says we run three times a week rain
or shine regardless of the weather or
the temperature please keep saying
there's now a smattering of people in
the room
and he looks out at them and he says the
next time you're out there before the
Sun is up it's dark it's cold and it's
wet and you're running by yourself we're
the ones standing under the Lamppost
cheering you on
that's how he described Nike in an
instant you understand what just do it
means just do it has nothing to do with
winning it has to do with trying and if
you look at the history of their
advertising Bo knows this and all of
those things it had nothing to do with
it my favorite one was the kid who takes
the steak did you ever I don't know if
you remember this whole TV commercial
you know kid in somewhere in Latin South
America it takes a takes a soccer ball
puts it on the kitchen table takes a red
raw steak out of the fridge and wipes
the blood all over the soccer ball and
then he goes outside and puts it on and
all the dogs in the neighborhood sniff
the blood and they start running and
chasing him and he's kicking the ball it
has nothing to do with winning it has
everything to do with trying
it has everything with doing
and his story his ability his narrative
captured that so exquisitely and when
Nike's at their best they celebrate the
ones who do not the ones who win and yet
ironically it's one of these major
sports brands and I think you have an
amazing opportunity for people to fall
in love with you the same way we fall in
love with Nike
let's get to the audience
well we have some time for some audience
questions so if I believe we've got some
mics around the room
thank you Simon thank you for sharing
your personal story and why purpose is
important for each of us not only for
companies really move and touch with
your comments
um in this company we call responsible
drinking promoting responsible drinking
we call it smart drinking
how do you see the role of my drinking
into our purpose going forward
um I
I don't think so smart drinking is a
practical necessity for the product that
you have
because it has alcohol in it right like
there there is actually a healthy and
there's a safe and unsafe component to
to your product right like any product
like you know if you make a car we want
you to drive not like a crazy person
like you have to drive responsibly you
know
um uh and so your if your purpose is
about community and taking care of each
other if your purpose is about dreaming
big and and creating a world where
there's more cheers I think one of the
things that
um instilling responsible drinking or
smart drinking actually is a is actually
less about the individual because if
they got the point where they drank too
much I don't know you know they don't
usually stop uh it's about our friends
it's usually our friends who say I'll
drive
it's our friends who say I think you've
had enough
it's our friends who say just one more I
actually think smart smart drinking is
it is very much built in your purpose
when it's done the best
um and and I think to say that every
individual person has responsibility for
themselves at all misses the point of
what it means to be a human being so I
think if we can inspire people to take
care of their friends who've reached the
limit I think that that really captures
your purpose
thank you Simon do we have additional
questions I'm sure we do I see see a
hand on the back there there you go
it's Carla
Carla great hi hi Simon thanks for
sharing everything with us I have a
question on vulnerability we have a
massive Cultural Revolution going on and
we see like here High leadership uh
really engage with that yeah there is a
difficulty like we we say that we are
not leaders anymore that know all the
answers but we learn everything but it's
difficult in practice to be vulnerable
and to accept and not being able to have
all the answers so if you can share with
us more on how to exercise vulnerability
and how us as we as high leaderships can
also influence middle management to to
to exercise vulnerability yeah thank you
um it's a great question and that word
scares a lot of people you know when
we're told you have to be vulnerable
right it's it's scary to a lot of people
it doesn't mean you have to walk through
the Halls crying every day that's not
what it means and what vulnerability
means simply is I'm willing to share
um as I said before I made a mistake I
don't understand I don't know I need
help because that is a position of
weakness right because as leaders we
think we have to know all the answers we
think we have to have we have to be
right all the time and the problem is is
when we when we project that
it actually has a has a it actually has
a negative impact which is we now put
pressure on people that they always have
to be right and they have to avoid the
answers because I'm always right and I
have all the answers in other words
you'll never get the truth out of
anybody
because that's the example that you set
being vulnerable when you say in a
meeting I you know I don't know or I
don't understand can somebody explain
that to me again what you're doing is
you're creating an environment where
other people can say I don't know can
you explain it to me and you get more
information that way but even I think
even expressing how we feel right
um I think people are afraid of that and
I think covid covet was a little bit
magical
um because we saw people at home we saw
people in sweatpants we saw people with
their kids running through the screen
and their cats jumping across and it was
imperfect
and things you know you lost the sound
and we had bad connection and it was all
fine everybody was patient and I really
appreciated that we learned to be
patient with people's Humanity
but
how many leaders talked about when they
were really struggling during covet
um I went you know at the beginning of
covid I called a friend of mine we had
to Pivot our organization we had because
what we made most of our money from
in-person events and I called a friend
of mine whose active duty military
and I said how do you compartmentalize
your emotions so you can stay Mission
focused because I gotta stay Mission
focused I don't have time to worry about
what's going on
and he gave me a very Stern warning he
said you can't he said no one can
compartmentalize their emotions he says
at best we can do it for a short period
of time but every single one of us will
suffer the trauma of combat he says the
hard part is you may not suffer it in
the moment you may suffer it four or
five or six months later after you've
been home already
he says so the stern warning is you're
going to suffer the trauma of covet at
some point
and I called all my a-type personality
friends and said we're going to be hit
there's no avoiding it no matter how you
know strong we think we are it's going
to hit us and we all made a deal to call
each other if we started to struggle and
sure enough one by one four five six
months into covid the phone started to
ring and people were really struggling
and we all made a deal that there's we
never cry alone if you have to cry you
call somebody that was the deal we made
with each other
and um sure enough almost on schedule
about four or five months in I started
to go through my depression
didn't was did struggle to recognize it
right was afraid to call it depression
because you know I'm a happy-go-lucky
guy I don't have depression I don't want
to be a diagnosed right but that's what
it was I was suffering Trauma from covet
and
um one of the first things I did was uh
talk to my team
uh well actually the first thing I did
was I called active military friend and
said what are your symptoms when you
suffered the trauma of
[Laughter]
and he said he answered my question he
said well
um I my my sleep pattern gets really
screwed up he said I go to bed really
late for no reason and I don't want to
get out of bed in the morning and I was
like yep and he's like I I don't really
want to talk to anybody I become really
anti-social and I'm definitely not
asking anybody for help and I was like
yep and he's like and um I'm
unproductive he says I'll have an
unproductive day and he goes that's okay
I'll I'll rationalize it that's okay
you're fine you've been busy it's okay
and they'll have another and another in
another and I'll keep trying to hide it
and I was like yep and that's when I
realized I was in it and so one of the
first things I did was I when I had we
had an all you know an all hands team as
we always do we had one of our company
uh All Hands meetings I said I'm I'm
going through it guys I said I'm really
struggling hard I said my sleep
pattern's off I'm not motivated I'm
struggling to ask for help I'm going
through this and I just need you to all
be a little patient with me I'm figuring
it out I'm sorting it out I'm asking for
help but I'm I'm not going to be very
good right now and I just need you as a
team I need you to be patient with me
that I did that to my team
made it possible for them to do that to
me
if I had pretended that I was happy
throughout all of it I would have put
pressure on everybody who is struggling
to pretend that they were being happy
and the worst part about that as a
leader is then how can I help
if I don't know
and we make the mistake very often that
when somebody's High performing that
they're fine because some people the way
they manage stress is to double down at
work so their performance will actually
be through the roof and they're
struggling really hard so performance is
no indication of someone's stress
and so I think when the ability to be
vulnerable is one of the greatest and
most difficult
Leadership Lessons any of us can learn
but it is so important to building trust
when people see us as human because it
allows them to be human too
do we have another I see in the middle
of the room
and if that whole story scared you if
you feel like you're going through
something like that call one of each
other I assume you have friends in the
room and do it to one person you know
I'm struggling what do I do
and you'll find that you can produce
tremendous courage when you have at
least one person who's got your back
I think I have Craig there right hello
I'm here
thank you Simon for the inspiration and
and also thank you for the challenge you
know about GE
be in the leadership Factor the past and
how can ABI become the new one right I
wanted to ask you
can you give us two or three examples of
what GE and Jack Welch got wrong and how
API should think about it differently
overcome the new leadership factor of
the future yeah absolutely
um
uh so in the in the without in the mid
to late 1970s of an economist by the
name of Milton Friedman offered an
entirely new definition of the purpose
of business he said the purpose of
business is to maximize profit within
the bounds of the law
that's a very low standard like what
about ethics right
but
this new definition of business which
was simply to maximize profit
believe it or not that wasn't the
definition of the responsibility of the
business prior right it was more uh Adam
Smith which is to produce great product
and great product is how we you know
take care of the consumer and that's
what makes us Thrive and all of that
stuff
um and it shifted the the focus of
business inwards and a lot of Executives
embraced it
and you started to see that miltonian
embracement of uh really start to gain
momentum in the 80s and was full-fledged
in the 90s and 2000s so it has nothing
to do with Republican or Democrat we saw
it Fly and we saw policy change to
embrace that definition so for example
there was no such thing as using mass
layoffs on a regular basis to manage the
numbers there was no such thing as mass
labs to balance the books prior to the
early 1980s it did not exist
it was used as a last resort when the
company was really losing money right
did not exist that's number one number
two the whole idea of rank and yank that
Jack Welch popularized where you rank
the entire company based solely on
performance you promote the top 10 and
fire the bottom 10 every single year
with no assessment as to are they
stabbing each other on the others High
performers bad for the culture stabbing
each other in the back for their
individual performance and of the low
performance struggling with other kinds
of issues maybe they're under stress
maybe it's market conditions who knows
didn't matter you get ranked you get
fired you get promoted guess what that
did to the culture everybody was
stabbing each other right
um the um the imbalance of shareholder
Supremacy
taking care of our shareholders was
always a thing that's not an issue but
it wasn't considered more important than
the customer or the employee we now live
in a world where the shareholder is now
considered more important than the
customer in the employee employee and
you hear bankers and CEOs talk they're
talking nonsense when they talk about
their fiduciary duty right it's
completely made up
um and that all was popularized by Jack
Welch he was the poster child for all of
these new ways of running business that
are now completely standardized one of
my favorite stories is actually from
Gary Ridge is the CEO he just retired
CEO of WD-40 which is a public company
and he was on his analyst call and his
analyst said Gary you missed your
numbers and Gary said
um no I missed your numbers my numbers
are just fine
um uh but uh but that all of that you
know the that that that that companies
are making decisions based on the 27
year old analyst telling you that what
you need to do so he can get his bonus
like that thanks we can thank Jack Welch
for all of that
I think we have Greg Boss Of course I
have strong opinions
by the way I'm also the first to admit
that the pressure is very very difficult
and overwhelming from the public markets
I don't mean to minimize it that it is
very difficult to find the courage to do
the right thing that you know is right
for your company despite all the
pressures from the external markets from
the external uh from the outside I don't
mean to diminish the pressures I know
it's huge but but uh there's already a
movement to start to push back and I
really I love that
so the same as a follow-up to that
you're talking about incentives in the
short term mindset so what's the right
incentive structure when you think about
the infinite game of business sure so it
has to be balanced there's no such thing
as a perfect uh Professor there's no
such thing as a perfect company let's
start there just like there's no such
thing as a perfect person despite what
we think about ourselves right that was
a joke the
um it's always a striving and it's
always constant Improvement and going
back to some of the stuff that Jack
Welch did which is the incentive
structures became
too lopsided where the performance of
the company actually was not how
Executives were compensated it was only
the the performance of the equity of the
stock and we think about that for a
second you know when a company announces
Mass layoffs the stock price usually
goes up and when they announce a huge
investment in r d the stock price
usually goes down
right which if you think about business
it's the opposite and so it's about a
rebalancing you know which is I think a
performance of company needs to be
included I think that long term needs to
be included
um
I think that adherence to values needs
to be included so that's all fine and
good you're you're a high performer and
your numbers are great but nobody trusts
you you stabbed a thousand people in the
back to get to the numbers you're doing
and you are actually damaging our
culture no you don't get a promotion you
know
um there's one company I know out there
who does what they call 50 50 bonuses 50
of your bonuses based on your numbers
and 50 of your bonuses based on
contribution to culture so if you hit
your numbers and you ignore culture 50
if all you do is walk around and check
on everybody but you don't actually do
any work 50 you know the point is and it
goes back to what I was saying before
unfortunately
there's not a lot that exists out there
about companies that have profoundly
changed these things especially in the
public markets you know
um it's very much the old ways
and there's companies that are
experimenting here and there with bits
and pieces but like really robust trust
measurements that can be included into
somebody's compensation package kind of
doesn't exist
and so this is where I'm chat where I
challenge ABI to think big which is
the metrics need to be invented and just
like Jack Welch either invented new or
created such an imbalance for the
metrics that have become standardized
today we need to invent new and re-re
recalibrate but I wish I could tell you
which company has done it
but it hasn't been done
not on mass anyway
right over here
thank you
um hello so Simon thank you very much
for for the thoughts and the comments
and Michelle and Kate and Jen thank you
for this session I I will say I find it
very valuable and took a lot of notes
and words already
but I'd like to
pull out one word Simon that you said
which was preacher at the very beginning
and ask a little bit about that word and
to dig into it because when I hear the
word preacher you know there has been a
lot of lack of trust in the world within
religion between countries media
government neighbors between you know
almost every every indication yep so
we're almost in a low trust world that's
here and yet we're trying to create a
high Trust Company and culture that's
centered around the purpose itself yeah
so my question is is when you think
about how you be an effective preacher
particularly for kind of this leadership
group where we are all tasked with that
very much and the purpose and living
that purpose and talking about that
purpose how do you be an effective
preacher not a false prophet and really
make it live and breathe in the
organization right what have you found
that works well so you you so the word
authenticity is bandied around a little
too much you know so it's kind of lost
its meaning a little bit but the true
definition of authenticity is that you
say and do the things you actually
believe
um and I believe these ideas the core of
my being
and the reason you can tell is because I
talk about them with great Passion
that's not you can't manufacture passion
like I can't give you a passionate you
know presentation about the migration
patterns of European swallows because I
don't care right and so
um to be passionate is is finding
connection passion is an output not an
input I always love that we only hire
passionate people well how do you know
that the passion of interviewing but not
for working you know passion is an
output like when I'm a part of something
bigger than myself when I love my team
when I feel supported what you get is
passion
you know working hard for something we
don't believe in is called stress
working hard for something we love is
called passion and so number one you
have to you yourself have to connect
with the purpose of the organization if
you find it corny or cheesy then this
may not be the place for you like you
you actually have to find personal
connection in it and and as Michelle
said before like in the past it felt
superficial and I've seen that a lot in
companies where it com where executives
are expected to go you know preach but
they don't even believe in it I ask them
in private like do you believe in like
no no really you know they can't even
like they have to read it they don't
even know what it is you know they kind
of remember it
um so you have to find connection at it
and more important you have to look for
examples that bring it to life both in
culture
um but even outside you know it's not
always product related as I talked about
before you know you know uh dreaming big
to to produce more cheers could be it's
an opera it's a mindset it's an
operating principle
um and so I think people are smart you
know you can you can fool them for a
little bit but eventually they catch on
and people ask me all kinds of questions
and what they find is consistency in my
answers and sometimes I'll say things
that are unpopular or sometimes that
I'll say things that you know maybe I
shouldn't say in public I am polite but
I still say the truth like I remember I
spoke at a large company we'll leave
their name out to protect the innocent
or the guilty and uh the one of the
c-level executives came up to me before
and he says listen I know you talk a lot
about layoffs and don't talk about them
in your session because we have an
unannounced uh round of layoffs that's
coming because we missed our numbers
right
so don't don't talk about it he
instructed me and I said to him very
polite like listen
I'm not gonna Target you I'm not going
to humiliate you and I'm not going to
bring it up but if somebody asks me a
question about it I'm going to talk
about it and he says I don't want you to
I said
then you shouldn't have hired me like
like you know who I am and
this is what you get like I I'm not your
monkey you know
um I didn't say that
um
he asked me to think about it and
somebody asked the question and I
answered it you know and I told them my
opinion about about what they do to a
culture and I understand that sometimes
they happen but they have to happen for
the right reasons and they can't happen
on a regular basis because the cost is
dramatic the damage we do to the culture
is dramatic so it's really really really
has to be worth it to do that much
damage and that much cost
you get the point and so
um I think to be effective preachers
which
um some of you will be naturally better
at than others it's not a problem this
is why we have each other we're Partners
but part of your job in senior
leadership is to is to is to embody love
of the brand
which doesn't necessarily mean you know
being a preacher it doesn't you don't
have to necessarily stand on stages but
you do get to find fun ways to bring it
to life like starting a meeting like you
can start every meeting talking about it
like dick Robinson who used to run
Scholastic they had an amazing cause
which is to inspire children to love
reading and he would bring it up in
every meeting remember what our cause is
it's to inspire kids to deliver and he
was constantly reminding people and
people loved it and believed in it it's
why they worked there I bring up our
cause we imagine a world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspired feel safe
wherever they are and end the day
fulfilled by the work that they do I
talk about it constantly I bring it up
in our own meetings with our own team I
make no assumptions that everybody knows
it no matter how many times they've
heard me say it
and I think I think that's what it means
to be a preacher which is look at real
preachers you know people who talk about
their
um their faith it it people people who
talk about their children right it's
like Ugh more about your kids right it's
like people when they have love for
something all they want to do is tell
you about it
and that's what it means to have that's
what I think it means to be a preacher
it means to have love
can you wait for the mic one second
question here in the back in your books
and conferences you talk about the
generational Gap especially for
newcomers into the workforce as senior
leaders here what advice can you give us
in practice to become more self-aware
foreign
and this younger generation seems to be
getting harder
because they're way more activists
millennials
were difficult but this younger
generation they're more activist which
when it's you know when it's like
climate change we love it but like when
you're like the intern and you're
sending an email to the CEO going I
don't think that you like it's like you
know there's other ways to do that
um
uh
it starts with empathy it starts with
empathy and we have to understand
it doesn't it's For Better or For Worse
the changing nature of what work has
become in our lives if you go back a
bunch of decades it used to be that you
got your sense of purpose from church
you got your sense of community from
bowling league you got you had you you
knew your neighbors you barbecued with
them on the weekends and work we were I
was loyal to work and work was loyal to
me at some point I'd get a gold watch
aside there's an entire generation that
when I talk about the gold watch they
have no idea what I'm talking about
right that's how much the world has
changed
um and and work was simply a place that
I made a living to pay my bills but
there was I still enjoyed my you know I
I it was still loyalty
over the course of time attendance
church attendance is down bowling clubs
don't exist anymore we don't talk to our
neighbors we become very insular and
what's happened is all of that pressure
is now being put on the office I now
expect my company to be the place where
I get my purpose the place I get my
friendships the place I get my community
at the place I get my social life now
we've also added the place you have to
agree with all of my politics
right that's a new one
and it's even now especially during
covet it's gone up even higher
especially for this young group where
you also have to be my my therapists my
therapy I'm going to bring all of my
problems to work
and where we the idea of emotional
professionalism seems to have gone away
you know where you actually see people
sitting in meetings like this you're
like what's going on having a bad day
right that's emotionally unprofessional
right you can I want you to bring your
emotions to work I want you to bring
whole your whole self to work but but
for the same reason that we exercise
emotional professionalism in other
aspects of Our Lives we also do it at
work
so one of the struggles of this young
generation is they are not equipped on
how to deal with stress
they're just less equipped than previous
generations for various reasons
including social media internet and all
that and you know parenting and all the
rest of it there's many reasons for it
but they're really not good at dealing
with stress they're really bad at
dealing with confrontation they're so
confrontation avoidable
that they would rather ghost someone
then break up with them after dating
them for six months
right that they would rather quit their
job than ask their boss for a raise
and usually in spectacular fashion like
you don't value me you don't pay me
enough you're like if you just asked I
would have given you a raise we love you
but they quit because they're just
afraid of the conversation
so they're very intimidated by
confrontation they're ill-equipped to
deal with stress
there's an emotional immaturity
emotional and professionalism
right and this it's not a good thing or
a bad thing it just is
and so us having empathy and
understanding that is important and so
it raises the question how are they
dealing with their stress not well and
so there's a new phenomenon that I'm
seeing happening in a lot of offices
where especially young people are
finding the one or two empathetic the
empaths on the team and they're going to
them with all of their problems and it's
not the traditional I hate my boss I
hate my job venting about work is fine I
have no issue with that but it's I hate
my mom I don't know what I want to do
with my life when am I going to leave my
house what I you know my boyfriend's not
working out my girlfriend's not working
out like every problem in my life on
this one or two people at work and we've
had it happen on our team we had three
people quit
and I got a little team I got three
people who quit because they said they
were burnt out and I was like
I know how much work you do what do you
mean you're burnt out so I'm like do you
have another job on the side
how can it be burnt out
you know
[Applause]
what I discovered
is they were the impasse on the team and
everybody was calling them to unload
they were burnt out because they were
taking on everybody's stress and they
were exhausted they couldn't take it
anymore and they just quit
and when I talked about this publicly I
had a 23 year old come up to me in one
of the companies and said
I do that
and so we have to recognize they are
struggling
in a changing chaotic crazy world right
now where there's so much uncertainty in
this world like like the world is always
uncertain but my God it's War and the
countries added each other's throat and
there's Challenger and the global
warming and it's just insane these poor
kids and they have no outlet they don't
know how to deal with it so my my big
challenge my big uh it's a challenge for
all of us is how do we hold space for
them and the problem is is they don't
even recognize when we're doing the
right thing for them that's the hardest
part
a lot of anger
um but it's it's gonna the problem is
it's going to take a bit like we're in a
period of extreme flux
and it's it's not going to settle for a
little bit where it's going to be very
bumpy a very bumpy road for the next few
years there's no right answer
and you will be you will be um
you know no good deed will go unpunished
you know but but but just keep trying
because they're people they're humans
and they're struggling
sorry for the long answer
hello hello first of all Michelle and
Simon I I I've been around here for a
long time and I just want to say thank
you for having the courage to open up
the space to even have a conversation
like this in a group like this so number
one thank you for for that that's very
encouraging I think my question is is um
you know having Simon and James back to
back is very interesting right because
we we have to manage the the quarterly
earnings and yet we have to have the the
faith to invest and make the right
decisions for the long time so Simon how
do we better manage that that that
inevitable tug of war between those
those two very important things that we
have to do the and versus the or and
again I'm tension is fine there's
nothing wrong with tension
um there's but it's recognizing that and
it goes back to the analogy I gave
before which is hitting a number doesn't
mean the game is over and missing a
number doesn't mean the game is over you
know and recognizing that that that we
have to survive is more important that
we have to we have to one of the
fascinating things during covid
was because most companies went into
such survival mode that literally zero
companies were concerned with what their
competition was doing literally zero no
one cared about their competition they
cared about survival well that's the
right attitude regardless of what the
economy is like don't worry about what
your competition is doing they're doing
great right worry about what you're
doing the only time you worry about your
other competitors is if they do
something better than you and you can
learn from them because their strengths
reveal to your weaknesses
and so there's nothing wrong with the
tension between the short term and long
term as long as you know that it's not
equal it's it's this long term is always
more important always
because if you focus successfully in
short term you're building a short-term
company look at GE it's a shadow of its
form of self and it's leadership you
have permission from the highest levels
to think that way
you have permission of the highest
levels to dream big and reimagine how we
think about our business
and
um and inevitably if you're going to
challenge the status quo which is in
challenge the way the public markets
currently work where you're forced to
make decisions from the outside that you
know are bad for your business every
every senior executive of a public
company knows that big Open Secret like
we all know that right
um that if we're going to start pushing
against those tensions we're not going
to do it an angry and aggressive way but
we're going to start pushing and there's
plenty of examples of companies that are
starting to push you know CVS when they
took all the cigarettes out of their um
out of out of their aisles because it
didn't align with their purpose Wall
Street had a conniption turns turns out
all the ebitda although the
um not the the uh
yeah it's the I've forgotten the
specific margin but the everything came
back within a week and the stock price
went crazy and the thing that the
analysts didn't know is loyalty from
customers and employees skyrocketed
skyrocketed that people would chose to
spend more money at CVS they didn't lose
any money
um when American Airlines decided to
give uh pay Rises to their flight
attendants and their pilots out of
contract
where Wall Street demanded that they
asked for something in return or not do
it wait till the contract expires and
American Airlines said no they're the
lowest paid employees in the in the
industry we have to do right by them and
ask for nothing in return American
Airlines actually does something that's
very sophisticated that I really
appreciated
um they have bifurcated their their
shareholder community so when they say
that they're shareholder driven they've
actually bifurcated the group into
long-term holders and short-term holders
and they actually Focus exclusively on
the long-term holders because the
short-term ones are fair weathered fans
they don't actually care what kind of
business you're running and if you're
doing well they invest in you anyway
and so
what what American Airlines did is they
literally ignored this group of
investors and they pay attention to
these so when they called those
investors and said we're about to give
this this big pay rise those investors
went it's the right thing to do go ahead
and do it we believe in you we know the
Stock's going to get hammered for a
short period but that's okay do it
though that's being shareholder driven
in a healthy way I thought that was very
clever but again they're pushing up
against the limits they're not they're
not coming in with a sledgehammer
Simon let me just make one question here
and then I'll go to you and helica uh
one thing that to me is interesting I'm
just wondering if you can give us some
ideas on that I was in can
uh and we saw that for the first time
like majority of the Lions and awards
they were given to brands
that presented work related to purpose
sustainability causes
so it's it's almost like if this
dominated the creative environment and
there was a lot of creativity but linked
to a purposeful execution and this
morning here we were talking to an
analyst
that was saying that for the first time
in many many months and quarters
majority of the conversations that he
has been having with investors is not
moving around escg sustainability and
things like that so what do you think
that the the current situation of
recession War economic crisis and this
new generation coming uh
we will provoke as a change so one thing
that are emerging Trends and disruptions
that will come so what are we going to
see five years down the road in can
what's the new big thing coming so I
think we forget that companies are
living breathing animals and you know
the ones that thrive over the long term
are able to adapt uh with changing
politics changing tastes changing
culture changing Technologies and we've
seen entire Industries disappear because
they were incapable of adapting to new
technology the internet's the best
example like literally didn't know what
to do they just went out of business
um or like if you look at television or
movies or music uh or or publishing
they're all still playing defense still
trying to catch up and figure out this
internet thing because they have these
old business models
um and I think it's a it's a powerful
thing when Larry when the uh The
Business Roundtable
you know makes a public statement about
the importance of
the importance of purpose weirdly signed
by you know Jamie dimon you know the CEO
of Johnson Johnson the CEO of of
progressive you know Johnson Johnson had
to pay 550 million dollar fine for its
role in the opioid crisis you know Jamie
dimon you know thinks purpose is how
much you give back to your community
like they don't they're not really good
Representatives what purpose is but the
point is the pressure from from the
market the pressure from from young
people and employees that this really
matters to us is actually forcing these
CEOs who they may have had to come to
Jesus moment that year all three of them
simultaneously may have happened but uh
uh but I just love that it means that
the thing that we stand for the things
that we're talking about here are
actually shaping business and where for
too many years it was those folks who
are forcing us to do it their way now
we're actually
applying the pressure and they're
starting to talk like us even if they
don't believe it
and so I I I'm less concerned about what
the advertising looks like in a five
years because I think the advertising is
a reflection I think the advertising
simply reflects what people want to hear
so the fact that they want to hear that
I think is fantastic
um
my aspiration is that companies actually
start doing it and not talking about it
that that it's one thing to make a piece
of marketing about it uh a piece of
advertising about it it's quite another
thing to make a strategic decision back
at your company about it so I'm hoping
that the the actions follow the words
um uh more
um but yeah no it seems to be going in
the right direction
a moment ago Judy's cost about the
relevance of the narrative
um my question is if you have any advice
or a benchmark on how to do this in a
very bold manner outside how to position
a good Narrative of our purpose that
you've helped us to create outside
so there's many ways to do narrative
there's no right way I mean one of the
ways it shows up obviously isn't going
to be in some of your marketing
especially your brand work of course I
think there are some very clever things
you can do at a product level and this
is what I love about purpose when you
have clear and compelling purpose it
starts to make you creative right at
every level
um so for example and again learn learn
from your worthy Rivals do you remember
a bunch of years ago one of the soda
companies I think was Coca-Cola they put
people's names on cans and you just
remember just for a while it was just a
marketing thing I mean you could write
things on cans
um
uh that that capture the spirit of what
cheers means I mean you could write
cheers but but you can actually write
statements like this is for this is
because I this cheers because I love you
choose because congratulations like you
can write those things on the cans and
you can start to do it in product that's
that's narrative you're starting to tell
your story through your product also the
way you talk about
um your jobs quite frankly you know if
if I ask the average employee at ABI if
I were to sit next to them on a plane
and say what do you do the dreaded
question right what do you do oh I'm a
marketing manager at Anheuser-Busch
okay
right
um what it what would it mean if they
were to actually say something at high
at a higher level than that oh um I get
to help find new ways to bring people
together to celebrate each other and
take care of each other that's amazing
how do you do that I'm actually a
marketing manager at an Azure bush
right where when narrative starts to
seep into the into the culture people
start talking about the cause before
they start talking about their jobs
you know
um uh
Marines if you ask if you ask somebody
in this in the Army what do you do to
say oh I'm I work in the Infantry blah
blah blah if you ask Maureen what do you
do this I'm a Marine
that's what comes first it's the global
right it's it's the membership
um I think I think every time you go
give a every time you show up on
television and every time you you know
you give a public speech goes back to
that story of
um Phil Knight and I'm not proposing you
you know you tell Phil Knight Phil
Knight type story but the point is is
like you're going to go on Squawk Box
and they're going to say they're going
to ask you a question and your ability
to talk about your cause not you know
sometimes the literal words but
sometimes in interpretive words
um and how you imagine the company
coming to and what bold means you know
what what dreaming big means and sharing
some of those dreams and like we're a
company that says we dream big let me
tell you what we mean by let me tell you
some of the dreams we have
and you can talk about how you're you're
changing your incentive structures you
can talk about how you're challenging
old Notions of business you can talk
about how the world is changing and
you're not going to follow the change
you're going to lead the change this is
all narrative and it all is based on the
same the same core so to answer your
question there's no right answer but if
you listen to all of the different
narratives they all have a flavor
you know it's like somebody asked before
like what what is how am I an effective
preacher if you go watch any video I've
made and if you go read any book that
I've written you can you can feel that
there's a theme
that theme is always there and people
are smart people can discern themes and
so the more consistent you are in all
the different ways you bring it to life
people start to understand what that
theme is
like Disney it's always there
I think we have time for one more right
that's right I see Philippe there
nope
Simon
um
how do you see companies measuring
success towards the purpose
like usually how our company is
measuring or like if they are far enough
far or close to to achieving an up your
purpose or your dream you know
so purpose is always idealized right
like as I said before I imagine a world
in which right I know I'm not going to
get there like when Martin Luther King
said I have a dream like one day little
black children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
right like all of these things they're
all striving
and the the Milestones that we pass make
us feel like we're making progress and
that's why metrics are really important
and Milestones are really important and
the most important thing is context
there's nothing wrong with quarterly
numbers annual numbers the only question
I would ask is to what end
to what end like you know I was talking
to a young entrepreneur last night and
she's looking for investment and one of
her potential investors said
um how long is it going to take you to
hit a hundred million dollar revenues
and I said don't take that person's
investment
show me one article one I just need one
show me one article in hbr one study I
don't care that demonstrates that hyper
growth or high speed growth is good for
is good for the company on any level
the answer is there are none
the pressure comes from that person
trying to achieve their financial goals
so they put pressure on you to make your
short-term goals right and so
um and so there's nothing wrong with
goals as long as we understand the
context and the purpose of that goal
right
um I like to think of money like fuel
right and a car is the company and the
purpose is the destination right and if
money is fuel it makes the car go you
absolutely have to money to make the
company go you have to have you have to
there is no dreaming big if you have no
fuel you can have the most beautiful car
in the world
and yet if you've got no fuel it's
pointless but we don't own a car to buy
fuel
right we don't own we don't have
companies simply for the money
right it's the destination you want to
be able to go somewhere and the and the
passengers are the employees and they're
excited not about the fuel in the car
how much fuel do we have no one gets
excited by that
we get excited where we're going
we're going to Alaska
are we near
and it's and and that's the analogy and
when there's a roadblock
if you're only driven by by uh the
metrics then the way we think about
money the way we think about corporate
goals the same way we think about our
goal is to drive 200 miles a day our
goal is to make x amount of money right
that's how we think about it well what
happens if you drive 150 miles
is that a problem what happens if
there's a roadblock
do you know what to do you start
freaking out and panicking because
you're going to miss your numbers we're
Purpose Driven
companies that know their destinations
in the idealized state they take detours
and to the outside world that looks like
you're going sideways or slowly but you
know you're just going around
and that's how companies actually look
you know it's circuitous and messy and
purpose helps us keep focused on the
very far distant future so we know we're
going in the right vector
even if somebody can't tell we're going
the right direction and so people have
to understand the purpose of the goals
you're setting and how they're
contributing to something and start
talking like we and our p l
I don't have the word profit on my p l
it doesn't exist
on my p l it says freedom
I damn well want more freedom this month
than I had last month
right freedom to say no to things that I
want to do
freedom to give it away freedom to take
care of my people
I want freedom because profit means
nothing so I'm trying to contextualize
all of these words that have no inherent
inherent magic to them
so yeah think of money like Fuel and
fuel drives your purpose be Purpose
Driven and talk about the place you're
trying to get to and talk about the
world that you imagine
and you damn well better make a lot of
fuel to get there because it's going to
be expensive and it's going to take a
long time
thank you both thanks so much
okay